en 1645 la corporation des chirurgien
barbier d'orléans commande une grande
série des médecins les plus célèbres à
pierrefonds sait qui est un peintre
or les années par mieux évidemment
figure vésale grands chirurgiens
italiens qui a complètement réformé à la
renaissance la connaissance du corps
humain
à
on
plus soin de se faire représenter en bas
du tableau dans les médaillons pour
qu'on se rappelle leurs actes de mécénat
quelque sorte
on
pour réaliser son portrait pierre ponce
et c'est tout simplement inspiré d'un
portrait commandé par vl lui-même pour
illustrer son traité sur le corps humain
fort très grave et qui est arrivé
jusqu'à lui au 17ème siècle et qui la
plus copiée parfaitement ans et qui a
recommencé à bien copié le visage de dl
laissant d'ailleurs le seul tableau
connu de lui
c'est très important et très connus
aujourd'hui en revanche le bras est
quelque peu fantaisiste et il semblerait
que pierre pensée n'a pas pris le temps
de bien lire le traité du modèle qu'il
représentait
en